[Musique]
descendez
est situé au milieu de la Suède au
milieu de la Scandinavie dans la
partie nord de l'Europe
étrangère
[Musique] [
Musique]
une région très sauvage avec de nombreuses
montagnes enneigées et c'est plus une
question de plein air  dans la vie, on l'
appelle la ville d'hiver, donc la plupart des
événements qui se produisent dans cette ville se déroulent en
hiver, il y
a généralement des événements sur
le lac parce qu'il a gelé, il est gelé, donc
vous sortez sur la glace et vous pouvez faire du
hockey et du patinage  et le ski le ski de fond le ski
tout le monde sait le ski le ski a
une bonne réputation c'est bien d'être célèbre
pour le bon ski
est
[Musique]
une ville située au bord d'un lac appelé station
c'est un immense lac le cinquième plus grand de
Suède
mais il a plus d'eau que certains  des
autres grands à cause de la profondeur
du lac,
c'est un très grand lac, une
partie est très profonde
et c'est de l'eau sombre, il suffit de parcourir
un ou deux mètres à la surface et
il fait complètement noir
et à la fin  en bas c'est
noir
Origines
étrangères
[Musique]
étrangère
qui existerait dans le lac euh dans n'importe quel
lac c'est énorme
[Musique]
étrangère
Je décrirais le monstre du grand lac
comme une
[Musique] qui
ressemble un peu à un serpent  être un long animal qui
monte et descend dans l'eau
comme ça
[Musique]
il se déplace très très vite, il fait environ plus
de 10 mètres et il est gris noir, il a des
bosses mobiles
et il a probablement une tête qui ressemble à
un chien ou peut-être à un cheval
presque comme quelque chose entre un serpent
et un dragon
peut-être un cousin pour faire certains endroits ou un
fan de tacos qui bouge
de l'époque des dinosaures avec un long cou
et une petite tête et un grand corps
j'ai pensé à quelque chose à la surface que je
ne peux pas expliquer grand noir magnifique  c'est insensé, c'est
effrayant,
alors bien sûr,
c'est quelque chose, mais ce que c'est,
nous ne le savons pas en fait.
[La musique]
est
[Musique]
le plaisir du verre,
c'est [
Musique]
les gens y pensent et en parlent
pas tous les jours mais absolument chaque
été parce que chaque  l'été, quelqu'un
le voit et c'est dans le journal que
quelqu'un l'a vu donc je dirais que c'est comme
euh,
un morceau de conversation chaque année,
il est toujours là
ouais je pense que c'est très connu ici
dans cette région,
la plupart des gens connaissent quelqu'un qui l'a vu
ou qui en parle  à ce sujet
et c'est le seul monstre récent que nous ayons
en Suède donc il est bien connu en Suède
aussi, la plupart du temps, il y a peut-être un ou deux
articles dans le journal chaque année
sur les gens qui ont vu le monstre et
bien sûr tout le monde ne va pas à
la presse  pour parler de leurs
observations, donc je dirais qu'il y a peut-être
environ
cinq ou dix personnes chaque année qui prétendent
avoir vu le monstre, mais
tout le monde n'est pas
aussi ouvert à ce sujet, c'est
[Musique]
où
c'est un magasin de trois mots
pour une grande
[Musique]
pour un  bête
erreur J'ai vu ce monstre du grand lac
en 1982.
vous
euh
étranger étranger étranger
étranger
le monstre du grand lac en 1977.
le 10 août
j'avais 16 ans et je rentrais
chez moi en vélo
et j'étais  en baissant les yeux parce que je voulais
voir si une voiture arrivait, alors je
faisais comme ça et il n'y avait pas de voiture
mais juste pendant une fraction de deux secondes, j'ai
réussi à voir quelque chose d'énorme monter dans
l'eau là-bas,
c'était noir et  c'était comme ça
et de la taille d'une Volkswagen et noir
dans l'eau
alors j'ai pensé qu'est-ce que c'était
mais à ma gauche j'avais trois
messieurs âgés de 40 à 50 ans et ils étaient
très contrariés et ils parlaient fort
et pointaient du doigt et comme  ça et j'ai
réalisé alors que j'avais probablement vu ce qu'ils
appellent Studio,
je n'en ai eu qu'un aperçu mais comme n'importe quel
enfant l'aurait fait, je suis redescendu au
lac
et puis j'ai eu la deuxième observation de
[Musique] étrangère,
je pouvais voir que c'était  comme deux à trois
mètres de long au-dessus de la surface comme ça
et il nagé pas comme ça
ou comme ça mais tout droit comme
dans un bateau renversé, ce qui est une
description très courante de cet animal
que beaucoup de gens ont vu et que l'on retrouve
et  encore une fois dans les articles,
euh, la peau de l'animal était foncée
ou plutôt noire je pense et cela
me rappelle ou me rappelait la peau de baleine,
il n'avait pas de poils ou quelque chose comme ça
et la vitesse était, vous savez si
tu fais du jogging comme ça, c'était la vitesse
alors j'ai marché à un rythme similaire et
sur une certaine distance et j'ai eu cette idée
et je n'en suis pas fier mais je ne
vais pas mentir à ce sujet, je pensais que je voulais
voir plus que ça  Je voulais voir
la tête
alors j'ai ramassé une petite pierre comme celle-ci
et j'ai pensé que si je la frappais dans le
dos, elle pourrait lever la tête, c'était la
pensée d'un jeune de 16 ans et j'ai jeté
la pierre à
l'étranger.
Je n'avais pas peur quand  Je l'ai vu j'étais en
sécurité sur terre mais je n'aurais pas
voulu être dans un bateau à ce
moment-là je peux te dire que
[Musique]
merci
fêtes observations
je m'appelle
j'ai vu le grand monstre du lac d'
environ  trois quatre mètres de distance
étrangère
[Musique]
ils avaient une force
des attaques d'Esprits
sur l'hélice
est
étrangère étrangère
[Musique]
et c'est là que nous avons tous les restes
de l'ère viking, les tombes nous
avons la runique  Pierre
qui est la seule dans cette région,
elle a été taillée entre 10h50
et 1070, nous pensons
euh
[Musique] [
Musique]
la pierre runique raconte l'histoire de qui
a construit le pont entre la France et l'
Irlande et de ce qui est maintenant une gare
et aussi de  la christianisation de
ces terres qui a eu lieu à cette
époque,
l'image du dragon lui-même comme
le seul dragon
représenté sur une pierre runique en
Scandinavie pourrait signifier que quelque chose que nous
ne savons pas
pourrait être lié à un ancien
folklore viking ou quelque chose comme ça qui  c'est
très intéressant
[Musique]
c'est
dans les années 1650, je pense que c'est la première
personne à écrire quelque chose à ce sujet
qui cuisinait près de la mer et
tout à coup c'était un big bang
et un chat sautait de la
cuisine et sautait juste en bas  au
grand lac,
alors nous savons que les gens en parlent il y a
plus de 400 ans
[Musique]
étrangère
en 1894, notre député Johns
Premier a affirmé qu'il avait vu le monstre
avec certains de ses amis et ils ont
décidé de le poursuivre  alors ils ont pris des
fusils et des bateaux pour essayer d'attraper
l'animal mais il allait trop vite et
il a tout simplement disparu
dans les profondeurs et il a en fait dit à la
presse qu'il avait vu l'animal et
qu'après cela, nous pouvons voir
la montée  des observations de
l'animal parce que bien sûr, si une personne
avec un rang aussi élevé dans la société
dit qu'elle a vu le monstre du grand lac,
cela doit exister
[Musique]
c'est probablement la seule fois où une
véritable fenêtre s'est ouverte lorsque les gens étaient
intrépides  ils en ont parlé et nous
avons des centaines et des centaines de
rapports de témoins dans les archives.
[Musique]
L'expédition a été une expédition très intéressante
et même le roi de Suède
a donné de l'argent à l'organisation de l'entreprise
parce que c'était très intéressant pour ce qui se passait
sous la surface.
Musique]
[Musique]
devant vous, vous avez le piège que
nous utilisions pour essayer d'attraper le monstre en
1980-94, nous y avons
mis un cochon et l'avons mis au bord du
lac dans l'espoir d'y faire entrer le monstre,
ici vous aussi  Je peux voir certaines des
autres choses que nous utilisons pour essayer d'attraper
le monstre. Ici, nous avons le harpon et
ils ont fait un grand trou dans la glace
et un homme se tenait près du trou avec son
harpon et il espérait qu'il verrait
le monstre et ensuite il  J'ai pu le harponner
mais le monstre ne s'est jamais montré donc
ça n'a pas réussi
[Musique]
directeur adjoint de Yantly, c'est important
pour nous de montrer l'histoire du
monstre et les histoires de toutes les
personnes qui ont vu le monstre parce que
c'est un si gros  et l'histoire importante de
la région, les gens voient ce
monstre depuis 400 ans, nous ne pouvons pas simplement
l'effacer de notre histoire, c'est une
partie importante donc nous ne pourrions pas vraiment
construire un musée sans lui,
merci
[Musique]
la
population,
c'est en fait un embryon du
monstre du grand lac, il a été donné au musée
le 1er avril 1986.
mais il est très difficile de voir si c'est
réellement le monstre du grand lac ou si
c'est un embryon ou autre chose, mais la
partie amusante est  qu'il a été donné le
1er avril, jour de la nourriture
[Musique]
élévation du monstre du grand lac et
comme vous pouvez le voir, la plupart des observations
se situent autour d'Austin, c'est dans les
opérations
[Musique]
ce n'est en fait pas mis à jour
depuis 20 ans mais c'est toujours le  même
schéma aujourd'hui,
donc nous voyons le monstre là où
vivent les gens, c'est là que se trouvent le plus d'
observations.
Nous avons peut-être cinq à dix témoins ou
histoires chaque année dans les médias locaux et si
vous pensez que peut-être un sur
dix qui voit quelque chose, dites-le à la presse.
eh bien, nous parlons de milliers
de témoins
[Musique] c'est
comme ça que je pense que
parmi les gens qui ont été témoins de cela, il y a
cette association appelée libre et
institution, ils ont des réunions sur une
base annuelle, ils se déplacent de ville en ville
autour du lac comme ça  chaque année, de nouveaux
Témoins viennent à ces réunions,
généralement il y a environ 80 à 100 personnes,
donc ils se réunissent chaque été et
ensuite
ils peuvent parler ensemble de ce qu'ils
ont vu
et c'est sérieux L'
association est une expérience
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
relaxation
ça peut être jusqu'à cinq six mille personnes qui l'ont
vu mais
beaucoup d'entre eux ne parlent pas
et chaque soir nous avons ceci, ils arrivent
de nouveaux Témoins,
certaines personnes arrivent et disent eh bien,
j'ai vu cela en 1945, j'ai gardé le secret, je
n'ai pas  Je n'en ai pas parlé mais tu entends toutes
ces histoires et puis tu commences à
penser combien de personnes ont vu ça
doit être un bon nombre d'
associations
[Musique]
Je ne peux pas dire que j'ai vu le même animal
deux fois ou  s'il s'agissait de deux
individus différents, le premier titre était
évidemment énorme, le second
n'était pas tout à fait le même
qu'après le premier,
mais vous savez qu'il y a forcément
une sorte de famille parmi eux, comme une
population qui peut peut-être
communiquer d'une manière ou d'une autre.
[Musique]
mais on dit le monstre du grand lac,
je préfère dire
les monstres du grand lac parce que
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait qu'un seul
monstre animal quel qu'il soit, il doit y en
avoir plusieurs car on peut remonter 1
000 ans en arrière  maintenant
et je ne pense pas que
le monstre ou quoi que ce soit puisse
être si vieux,
il est très intéressant que lorsque la
période glaciaire s'est arrêtée, de nouveaux lacs ont été
créés qui étaient connectés à la mer
et je crois que quoi que ce soit, il
a  être une famille de quelque chose qui
existait autrefois dans la mer et qui vit maintenant
dans ce lac,
quelque chose que nous pensions peut-être
éteint, pourrait être une sorte de
parent peut-être du Plésiosaure ou
quelque chose que je ne connais pas, mais beaucoup de
gens ont vu le  long cou et ce que
j'ai vu, comment pourrait-il nager comme ça
s'il n'avait pas de nageoires et peut-être qu'une
sorte de queue l'aidant à se déplacer
devrait être plus naturel, ce
serait au moins un poisson parce que s'il le
faisait  être un émail, alors où est-il
livré pendant l'hiver,
je veux dire où prendre l'air et se reproduire, c'est
pourquoi je pense que ce devrait être un
poisson,
certains plongeurs ont vu de grandes collines,
cela pourrait être les deux
gros poissons et cela  pourrait être quelque chose
que nous n'avons pas encore découvert ce que c'est pour
le moment
étranger
[Musique]
je m'appelle
et je suis un chrysologue
cryptologue sur les animaux dont
l'existence n'est pas prouvée et crypto signifie
caché
et le puits de l'astrologie Animal  Royaume
Je ne me considère pas comme un croyant
parce que ce n'est pas scientifique de
croire en des choses, il vaut mieux garder
l'esprit ouvert et j'ai l'esprit assez ouvert
sur le fait qu'il y a quelque chose dans le
lac, je ne sais tout simplement pas quoi.
M. stocke
[Musique]
dans la société scientifique, il
y a un
sentiment très anti-cryptosologie
euh,
cela relève presque de la même chose que les
observations extraterrestres ou les fantômes
euh et ils trouvent que ce domaine est une cause perdue
[Musique] [
Musique]
le plus
sceptique et professionnel  Les sceptiques, les
scientifiques utilisent la même explication
pour chaque observation de monstre marin
partout sur la planète, un grand poisson-chat, un
gros journal, des phénomènes météorologiques. Des oiseaux,
oui, des élans qui nagent, mais je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit
très courant dans d'autres parties du
monde, il y a des gens qui ne le font pas.  ils croient
en ça et ils ne vont pas à nos
réunions et n'écoutent pas
et je dis que c'est impossible et ils pensent
qu'ils sont fous
[Musique]
ils n'appellent généralement pas les gens des menteurs en
face mais dans leur dos
tout d'un coup oh il veut être dedans  dans le journal,
il a dit que c'était un monstre,
très triste,
ça m'énerve vraiment que les gens qui ont vu
ça, euh,
soient traités comme ça, c'est comme des balles
dans la cour d'école, une sorte de situation. L'
observation de M. Festine est l'une des très
bonnes
et il travaille si dur et il  lui, tu
connais des gens comme ça, tu ne devrais pas les
rabaisser, je pense que c'est honteux,
mais un jour, tu sais que des gens comme lui et
d'autres qui travaillent avec ça seront
justifiés et tu sais,
j'espère que cela arrivera d'ici quelques années,
je ne sais vraiment pas pourquoi  les gens croient
ou ne croient pas mais je pense que les
gens
qui croient au monstre, au monstre du grand
lac, ont en fait vu
quelque chose qu'ils ne peuvent pas expliquer
autrement que par le fait que ce doit être un animal,
oh, vous pouvez le voir  dans d'autres pays
également, les monstres des grands lacs ont
des cousins ​​en Écosse, en Norvège, aux
États-Unis et partout dans le monde, donc ce
n'est pas seulement pendant une saison que nous voyons ce
genre d'animal, donc cela doit être quelque chose
que l'être humain  C'est voir et
essayer d'expliquer que partout dans le monde,
nous découvrons de nouveaux animaux presque chaque
année, de nouveaux requins, de nouveaux phoques et peut-être que nous
avons quelque chose d'extraordinaire ici qu'un
jour nous serons juste une
sensation complète et ensuite nous aurons les
scientifiques qui viendront ici
et  ils diront que je te l'ai dit
[Musique]
existence
étrangère [
Musique]
[Musique]
dans le Grand Lac
et nous descendrons à environ
maximum 80 mètres
étrangers
pendant deux jours c'est une
journée de théorie le lendemain c'est  deux plongées
que nous allons regarder le monstre,
nous avons cette histoire du monstre donc
c'est amusant de la prendre et de voir ce que vous
pouvez trouver
[Musique]
la maximisation est
étrangère [
Musique] [
Musique]
étrangère
[Musique  ]
mais
parfois, vous pouvez avoir l'impression que quelque chose
nous observe lorsque nous plongeons,
vous avez l'impression que qui est là, vous pouvez sentir dans votre
estomac lorsque vous plongez qu'il y
a quelque chose autour de vous, mais vous
ne pouvez pas vraiment être sûr de ce que c'est.  c'est
et la première fois que j'ai senti que
mon pouls augmentait
et je dois me contrôler un
peu parce que c'était un peu effrayant euh
mais ensuite j'ai levé les yeux et je n'ai rien vu, c'est
un peu  difficile à décrire mais
et je n'ai jamais eu l'impression qu'avant nulle part
ailleurs, ce
n'est pas tous les régimes que vous avez l'
impression que c'est un
type spécifique, mais plusieurs lundis,
j'ai eu l'impression que ça
riait,
ce n'était pas une bonne journée de grand monstre de lac
aujourd'hui
[  Musique]
et je n'ai rien vu, je n'ai
rien ressenti, c'était beaucoup de plantes
mais pas de poisson
et la nourriture principale du monstre est le poisson donc
oui,
je ne pense pas que ce soit par ici en ce moment
quand nous sommes morts ici la dernière fois  C'était plus l'
été
ouais donc je pense que c'est probablement devenu
plus profond maintenant pour l'hiver euh on
ne sait jamais combien de dés tu dois
faire
si tu as de la chance tu peux le trouver
quelqu'un doit mourir souvent
j'espère que j'en ai un  jour, sera-t-il un endroit, faisons ce qui est
bien pour toi et j'espère avoir mon
appareil photo avec moi pour pouvoir le montrer
au monde
[Musique]
aujourd'hui, nous allons rechercher les
monstres des grands lacs pour vous montrer
un peu ce beau temps
la mer est peut-être agitée mais le temps est tellement beau que
les conditions sont parfaites alors allons-y car c'est son
anniversaire
ouais,
un de nos membres a vu quelque chose
à l'été 2007 et cela nous a donné l'
idée de travailler avec les caméras que
nous avons derrière nous  maintenant, ce petit îlot
avec les caméras, vous pouvez voir les quatre
caméras sur la surface mais nous avons
aussi des caméras sous la Surface trois
qui recherchent le monstre en
temps réel donc vous pouvez le voir depuis le
Centre d'Observation
[Musique]
en
tant que
musée
ici  C'est ce que nous appelons la station de surveillance
où nous avons des
caméras en direct. Chaque fois qu'il y a un mouvement,
les caméras l'enregistrent et nous pouvons
revenir en arrière et le regarder et voir ce que c'est.
Cette technologie est tout à fait unique pour le
musée,
c'est très simple comme avec le  écran tactile,
vous n'avez besoin d'utiliser aucun outil et
tout le monde peut l'utiliser, de 70 ans à
trois ans,
le centre des monstres du grand lac
étranger
[Musique]
combiné à la haute technologie, c'est
pourquoi nous voulons que les gens viennent ici
et soyez un chercheur de
vidéos
pour ne pas savoir quand le moment sera venu
mais vous devez vous devez avoir la situation
et maintenant nous l'avons avec les vidéos des caméras
c'était dans la vidéo c'était une petite chose
comme un petit ver mais il a  un
mois intéressant juste une
bouche à l'envers ce n'est pas un poisson ce n'est pas une grenouille
mais elle avait une tête très intéressante
quand les gens du monde entier l'ont vue, ce
fut un big bang pour nous et puis, en trois
jours, un demi-million de personnes
arrivaient  sur le site, nous comprenons
que les gens du monde entier sont
très intéressés par des choses inconnues
et qu'un jour, grâce à la nouvelle
technologie, nous le saurons, mais pour le
moment, c'est très difficile et c'est un
grand lac que
les gens qui le font actuellement
sont  je le fais en quelque sorte à un endroit dans
l'espoir de le trouver là-bas, je suppose,
mais la science a encore un long chemin à parcourir, mais nous
avons besoin des nouvelles technologies pour
vraiment le découvrir, obtenir l'argent nécessaire pour
faire des recherches appropriées avec un
équipement sonar, etc.  à une échelle beaucoup plus grande,
c'est la réponse
[Musique]
oh [
Musique]
quand vous viendrez à Austin vous remarquerez
l'animal à pas mal d'endroits et
c'est évident que la municipalité d'
Austin veut vraiment en faire le
symbole de la ville
Je ne pense pas que les touristes soient attirés
par le monstre,
mais cela donne à la région une valeur particulière. Des
caractéristiques spéciales qui sont positives pour la
région.
Le monstre est, euh,
quelque peu important pour le tourisme à
Austin, mais il pourrait être plus important, je
pense.  nous hésitons un peu quant à savoir dans
quelle mesure nous devrions l'utiliser
dans le marketing de la région et de la
ville car d'un côté c'est un grand
symbole et nous aimons l'histoire et nous
pensons qu'elle est spéciale et d'un autre côté
certaines personnes pensent que c'est un  un peu
embarrassant ou devrions-nous vraiment
être célèbres pour quelque chose qui n'existe peut-être pas
Je pense que cela pourrait être beaucoup plus grand en fait,
je pense qu'ils l'ont sous-estimé le
potentiel touristique et ainsi de suite pour que
les gens sachent que ce n'est pas seulement une
ville ordinaire  nous avons quelque chose de spécial
ici Le
monstre des Grands Lacs est un
patrimoine culturel de l'Ymtland et en tant que
conservateur du musée et
directeur adjoint, je ne m'intéresse pas vraiment à savoir
s'il existe ou non, ce qui est important
pour nous, ce
sont les histoires que les gens racontent.  raconter
et nous sommes pleins de respect pour tous les
témoins et les personnes qui prétendent avoir
vu quelque chose parce que c'est le cas,
nous croyons absolument
qu'ils ont vu quelque chose et ce sont
leurs histoires que nous recueillons et
ce sont leurs histoires qui sont importantes pour
nous
Je pense que le grand public ne
s'y intéressera pas beaucoup
jusqu'au jour où
vous aurez les gros titres qu'ils ont maintenant
concluant à un travail à filmer ou quelque chose comme ça ou un
animal mort, alors ce sera une
sensation mondiale dont tout le monde parlera.  à ce sujet,
ce sera l'une des plus grandes histoires
de nos vies. J'espère vraiment que
de mon vivant nous découvrirons ce que c'est.
[Musique]